c'était le match à ne pas perdre pour
l'as poissy derniers du classement les
yvelinois recevait sainte geneviève pour
un derby francilien
malmenés en première période les joueurs
de laurent fournier encaisse un but à
zéro ce sera le score à la pause
la première mi temps pas grand chose si
ce n'est que pas beaucoup d'occasions on
s'en crée une ont fait une erreur sur le
côté un centre on est inattentif entrant
au but en 2e période fois ci revient sur
le terrain avec plus de combativité
l'épicier qui se procurent des occasions
et arrive à obtenir un penalty sur cette
main fabien raddas marque fois ci
revient au score un but partout à la 69e
minute de jeu mais sainte geneviève
marque sur l'une de ses seules occasions
de la seconde période de 2 à 1 ce sera
le score final
sentiment d'injustice parce que parce
qu'on a plus d'eau casey que je pense
que sur la deuxième mi-temps au mérite
on mérite au moins le point du match nul
ce résultat n'arrange pas poissy le club
s'enfonce au classement l'épicier qui
sont toujours bons derniers de la poule
avec déjà sept défaites
c'est rageant faut serrer les dents je
pense que même si on perd aujourd'hui
c'est de bonne augure dans le sens où on
fait une prestation correcte il ya des
matches où on fait des prestations
vraiment lamentable là aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on peut
reprocher à tous les acteurs de l'équipe
de poids si je sais pas grand chose on
va pas renoncer après
savez le football ça va vite eu
c'est moi je suis là pour entraîner pour
faire progresser un groupe c'est vrai
que c'est compliqué mais voilà on
s'accroche
voici tentera de se relancer lors de la
prochaine journée contre l'équipe
réserve de caen le 7 novembre domicile
laurent fournier ne sera pas sur le banc
l'entraîneur a été démis de ses
fonctions le lendemain de cette défaite
contre sainte geneviève